j'ai comme l'impression d'interrompre
une fête entre amis
et pour le coup intervenir en fin de
tedx surtout après tout tout
l'après-midi qu'on vient de vivre pour
moi ça c'est assez particulier je me
présente je m'appelle virginie mangeant
je suis donc mathématicienne
statisticienne moi même j'ai du mal à le
dire également sociaux psychologues
ethnologue
pour tout vous dire j'aime aussi la
physique quantique et les théories de
karl popper ce qui fait vous l'aurez
peut-être deviné deux mois une
chercheuse
je travaille donc dans un centre de
recherche qui m'a fait signer un contrat
de confidentialité de 46 pages 46 pages
à mon arrivée
vous pouvez bien sûr deviné et vous
l'avez deviné avec la présentation ce
centre de recherche traite des sujets on
ne peut plus sensibles à savoir la fin
du monde puisqu'il s'agit du centre
national d'étude de l'apocalypse ça a
l'air de vous amuser
très bien
donc le cnea ou centre national d'étude
de l'apocalypse mettons nous d'accord
tout de suite sur les termes vous savez
peut-être les scientifiques dans la
salle la rigueur scientifique m'oblige à
préciser un peu le terme d' apocalypse
entendons-nous bien il s'agit bien sûr
de l'extinction de -2 99% de l'espèce
humaine en un événement que je décrirais
peut-être si nous avons tant on verra
alors je passe le slide le cnea en
quelques chiffres des grands locaux
énormément de couloir beaucoup de gens
très très compétent forcément sauf en
matière de mise en page de diapositives
a priori
estimez vous heureux d'ailleurs qu'on se
concentre sur autre chose que
l'esthétisme de nos slide
voilà très ce prix nobel c'est une bonne
moyenne
c'est une bonne moyenne et 700 alors
pourquoi calculer la puissance d'un
ordinateur en mètres cubes trouvé ça
assez sympathique ça change des mega
mega machin de plus voilà il est grand
et donc qui dit grand ordinateur dit
forcément ordinateur puissant et
également beaucoup d'années de r&d
recherche et développement pour vous
présenter l'innovation si je puis dire
que je vais vous présenter ce soir
continuer à rire un petit instant
puisque nous au cne à nous savons nous
sommes en mesure de calculer de mesure
et de prédire je laisse ma dame se
ouais de prédire donc le jour exact de
l'apocalypse puisque on va terminer on
va continuer sur cette lancée positive
voici tu peux envoyer jean-louis le
décompte officiel de l'apocalypse
ça a l'air de vous satisfaire salaire de
vous rassurer très bien très très bien
on a conservé les secondes quand même
pas un effet un peu plus dramatique 300
67 ans pourquoi vous rigolez j'imagine
bien que vous vous dites
premièrement nous ne sommes pas
concernés tant mieux
et peut-être aussi comme nous vous savez
relativiser vous dites que l'apocalypse
peut au final s'avérer être une très
très bonne nouvelle
peut-être pas pour l'humanité en
l'occurrence mais par exemple pour les
abeilles n'est ce pas régis lippinois
les abeilles et éventuellement aussi les
fleurs et les plantes qu elles
pollinisent et de fait les animaux qui
mange ses fleurs et ses plantes qui sont
pollinisées par les abeilles et
éventuellement les animaux qui mange des
animaux qui mangent les fleurs et les
plantes
ce qui nous fait quand même grosso modo
une bonne majorité de la faune et flore
mondiale qui serait éventuellement super
content de faire la fête aussi dans
trois cent soixante sept ans voilà pour
la bonne partie de fait on peut craindre
bien sûr les pires déchaînement de folie
à mettons à 365 10 6 366 s'en aller
pour ma part j'ai réfléchi à ce que
j'allais faire juste avant l'apocalypse
et c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui ça s'est un
peu précises et mes projets se sont
précisées c'est à dire que je compte
bien danser nue dans le désert également
alors le désert du nevada où le désert
breton le centre bretagne
pardon monsieur martin
on serait pas invité aux vieilles
charrues cette année toute façon on
travaille beaucoup on n'a pas trop le
temps besoin de le gall et jeanne eux
j'en profite à monsieur bah oui
justement qu'est ce que je ferais avant
l'apocalypse
monsieur le boss il ya quelqu'un qui est
ça m'est tombé sur le coup il ya
quelqu'un qui vous a envoyé une une
tentative de papillons en meurent et
gamme ea a priori kkk pas rencontré
beaucoup de succès qui vous étaient
adressées je me permets on est entre
nous alors idée de film en 3d pour
monsieur monsieur le boss ben écoute et
on va lire ça ça vous vient de geneviève
bisou de geneviève pardon de geneviève
geneviève bisous alors idée de film en
3d alors un film qui fait pleurer un
film sur le cyclisme je vous propose de
faire deux pour le prix d'un avec
celui-là avec monsieur noah film qui
fait pleurer sur le cyclisme
geneviève si ça vous convient tant mieux
du tout ce sont elles ne dira pas que
c'est tel film inspirational à ça c'est
intéressant la vie je lis les
commentaires de geneviève encore une
fois la vie offre un pot de pus ps
geneviève le pus impôt de plus aux héros
à la vie offre un pot de plus j'imagine
à un cadeau empoisonné
un beau coup de pub au héros il ou elle
se bat pour et en fait profiter les
autres
alors j'ai une note sur le pot de pus
instar garde ou un mari adressez vous à
geneviève de toute façon n'est pas moi
qui écris ça un film qui fait peur la
revanche des abeilles tueuses sous
titres ils l'ont bien cherché
je ne renierai pas ce ce script à un
film d'amour en entreprise
intéressant
alexandre géré à l'entreprise du bonheur
avec debbie sensory à tous les étages on
dit donc pourquoi pas innovons martin
est ce que tu me prêterai ta tablette
s'il te plaît j'ai un dossier à finir à
l'eau
c'est parce que j'étais en train j'étais
en train de lire un compte rendu de
rigny je te le prête tout à l'heure pas
bon c'est le boulot ces boules on a quoi
d'autre les 50 nuance degrés dans les
ehpad alors maric que l'on peut dire
c'est comme les araignées sait on sait
que ça existe
on comprend que ça une fonction dans
l'univers mais c'est pas pour autant
qu'on veut les voir
voilà pour ça enfin et pardon c'est moi
c'est leur stop
ok ok un instant pas ok d'accord
non non non non vous inquiétez pas calmé
vous concerne et votre calme d'accord
personne ne bouge 1
c'est un fake c'est un fait regardez
trop évident c'est facile à un impact au
nucléaire visant la mayenne mais
personne ne vise la mayenne il ne se
passe rien en moyenne attendus j'appelle
juste voilà admis vous avez deux minutes
jamie ben oui sylvain tu mets ta s'il te
plaît voilà tu mettant ça le truc c'est
le support informatique de kia oui tu
mettant sa non non non non c'est pas toi
qui avec 1200 personnes facilement
excitables avec des issues de secours
pas tip-top sylvain alors tu mettant ça
s'il te plaît de seconde les issues de
secours sont très bien 1
elles sont aux normes elles sont aux
normes normal alors oui d'accord de
bisous bisous merci voilà alors on a des
procédures d'urgence au pea
dans ce genre de cas d'accord ne vous
inquiétez pas conserver votre calme
d'accord vous allez levez les bras s'il
vous plaît maintenant même les 3% de
couillon
même ceux qui ont payé moins cher
ce sera même prix pour tout le monde
beatty john parish going to be working
man hockey people damon et 3e loyer
mayenne ok conserver votre calme
vous allez faire un tour sur votre
gauche un quart de tour sur votre gauche
la vôtre la bonne celle là voilà et vous
allez baisser vos bras sur les épaules
de votre voisin très bien on en est où
une minute super alors masser votre
voisin pendant la fin du monde
faites vous plaisir y'a pas de raison
d'accords hockey fait le bien fait le
bien super vous conservez cette repose
continue à vous aimer aimez vous les uns
les autres
pendant la fin du monde
merci mon matin dans science
merci de rester calme pendant la famille
tout est allé de travers décidément
c'est faire du monde compris le message
aimons-nous les uns les autres en
attendant la fin du monde bordel merci à
vous merci à tout le monde